yeah okay we good on rolling all right
should we do masks I mean we can't do
the mass the entire time masks they all
look like Darth Vader at this point can
can you hear me I mean I probably
something better with a master test
probably not with my voice I think I
sound infinitely better with being
muffled maybe well now mine's more
muffled because it's my voice is
naturally muffled is it
I think people probably like this
because they can picture me being
suffocated and they like no I didn't
want I would love to I should I probably
could make them yeah it's a little like
maxi paddy like right here yeah I feel
like we could pull we could taper it
mine yeah yeah you're right it should go
down like this yeah like if we could
just we could
I mean look we're in the early stages of
wearing masks yeah I have a better one
though yeah just yesterday I wore it and
it got a little sweaty yeah we that's
the other thing you have to wash your
mass yeah your mask is not hygienic if
you don't wash it it defeats the whole
purpose of having one yeah and that's a
you know what to be sure to have some
fresh mints because you're smelling your
own breath in there so take care be kind
to yourself I kind of like wearing the
masks because I can like scowl of people
and they don't notice it made me realize
how much I like make faces at people and
how fun it is to be able to it's like an
invisibility cloak like I feel like
around and like stare at people that's
it for me cuz I'm a smiley person yeah
if I walk penny I want it I still like
to smile at folks I hope they know by my
eyes that as a good this might be good
for you to stop it's not my so much
the only way to fix like the fact that
you're too nice you're too inviting yeah
this is a great way to get people to
think you're a bitch yeah that's true
okay I'm starting to take this starting
to get swampy in here it gets it gets
very swamy so I'm going like here I'm
going like here okay
I always start the podcast asking the
guests if we're friends and I don't say
any this will be other you know the one
we get when we go back to dating it
they'll be like can I take it off yeah
sure okay
well wait wait I do want to talk about
that yes how are we gonna go back today
I don't I haven't in thought I haven't
like I don't even know I don't even know
I mean is it gonna be because I am
definitely inappropriately texting with
some of that I shouldn't be texting with
I think part of the reason I'm flirting
with him and texting with him is that
there is no chance that we can see each
other I'm being so reckless because I'm
ray you know I know that high and low
anywhere so I'm just throwing grenades
left and right right I'm gonna so
aggressive with someone like to the
point to where if if this were to stop
tomorrow I'd be like oh now it's like
well no I get that what about blue I
think this through like you're a DJ no
like I was bored
I had cabin fever I thought this was a
good idea I mean I am being so reckless
in quarantine I texted an ex on Sunday I
was so desperate for just some kind of
it's like that yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
needs like so I wanted to make a little
drama for myself I need to get into it
not just to be able to untangle it I
need some adrenaline yeah I texted an ex
it was a relationship that ended
horribly and I just wrote hoppy Easter's
like what do you do by off the Easter do
I get it like it ended like horribly Oh
I know I'm anyway I mean I guess I sent
some nudes you sent some nudes Melissa
Villasenor there's a guy before this i
hook up occasionally with and those you
know same thing it's just you just want
a little like oh damn looking good
so you just feel you know alive for the
day
wait I have to wait you just threw two
things at me number one you're taking
nudes and number two a guy you sleep
with occasionally I mean what does that
mean I guess just a hookup that's it how
is that I've never hooked up with
someone in my life without it being a
full-on emotional entrenchment I think
most of mine have been hookups so you
don't get emotionally attached to these
people no no I I think I do but I think
there's enough time and gap in between
seeing them then I'm okay well Melissa
just so everybody knows also the same
person that what no no I was gonna say I
I'm not a I don't I haven't been oh go
ahead I don't know what I was gonna say
I just want to work with Melissa's
personality in context for everybody
yeah you know her as this charming
brilliant elfin nymphet that has taken
over SNL with all of her charming
brilliant iconic impressions she's got a
dark side I do I'm a little freaky no no
you know I have like 11 tattoos I have
you know I want on a ribcage thighs I'm
like there's this little side that's
like Oh what what's in here in this it's
not it's not a little side I Melissa's a
fucking straight up Savage we were in
Vegas once Melissa and I used to tour
together and I thought of Melissa's like
the sweet little like like you're like a
um like the princess from Super Mario
Brothers one who's just like me long
beep I'm more like a toad you're careful
myself up my microphone it's at a new
configure I don't know what did I do in
Vegas we were in Vegas and you were
dating someone and I used just strike me
is like very innocent very proper very
just a pure you strike me as very pure
sweet in a sense
I I do have that site yeah yes and we
were talking and um and I was like you
were talking about dating and I was like
oh god I'm gonna have to hear this like
girl talk about how much she likes this
guy and she wants to get married and she
wants the whole thing and I'm like so
how come you're not dating right now and
you just want I just I don't I don't
want to listen so I feel the day like
gangster like I don't want to listen to
a man rare I don't care I just want that
dick yes I don't want to hear where you
went to school I don't care about it
like so when you're listening to a guy
tell you about where he went to school
or you're just like this is what I have
to put up with in order to get that day
yes and then I think also I smile
manok for for stand up for work yeah
everyone yes and so going on a date and
being like yeah yeah did you go - yeah
it's like I don't want to do I don't
want to I know if it does it feels like
work yes my face hurts just from having
to listen to someone talk about
themselves mm-hmm do you find that guys
try to make you laugh and be funny
around you I've gotten plenty of dates
like that but nothing these days cuz I
just won't have it I think now my rule
is when I go back on the dating scene I
just want I better hear their voice on
the phone uh-huh
get their vibe before we even physically
go out because I don't want to waste my
time anymore with that you better
already be vibing with me to where we
both laugh at the same beats but why is
it that if a guy said this it would be
so incredibly sexist
I like the were allowed to say this now
we act like men it's like cool and
triumphant and like feminist about us if
a guy said anything you were saying Oh
mence would be brutal right it would be
Dan Bilzerian it would be a monster
time's up on this let you don't mean
we're allowed to just be like I want
that dick don't want to hear what you
have to say don't even want to hear you
talk don't even care who you are right
yeah well whatever it's we'd you'd be
Andrew Dice Clay
[Laughter]
literally and I do have a dice claim but
I think I think it's inch I think you
had definitely have been in
relationships where you cared about the
purse
oh yeah no no I won in we've had such a
metaphor because I think everyone's dog
is exactly like them dog is currently
just nying nying on my savagely in a
sweet way anyway penny no I love it just
if you guys hear a furious growling it's
penny oh yeah it's Melissa's inner
monologue so what happens you don't want
to be in a serious relationship
you just want no strings attached
hookups I think if I feel like oh this
this dudes so cool I I like him I'd feel
it you know if I just don't I don't but
you can separate it you can go okay this
is not a person I should date this is a
person I could just see oh yeah I think
now now I'm like oh yeah that's person
clearly not at my level of greatness
because I used to go this guy's like a
c-minus let me just put a bunch of work
he's a fixer-upper
let me put him under and work into him
make him an A and then he can be my
boyfriend you're able to go like you're
a c-plus let's just sleep together as I
wait for the A+ to come along yes is
that kind of that's how I roll so you're
gonna put the word I don't want I won't
do the word
it is weird though because if you're
dating a guy who's hot and you start
listening to talk about themselves
you're like oh someone has listened with
someone that you know someone pretended
this was interesting at some point so
now I I'm an asshole cuz I'm just not
gonna pretend you don't I mean the girl
before me set me up to look like a dick
she didn't want to hear this shit either
man you're so good she pretended so I
have I have two sets of bad news number
one everything you're saying is boring
and number two the girl before you faked
interest and orgasms so we need to
regroup but what are people supposed to
talk about well I don't know that's why
I have any mitten what do you find
interesting
what can a guy talk to you about where
you're not gonna get bored I don't
actually that's
I haven't even thought of that yeah I
just think where I'm at right now I just
feel like I'm here to bring joy and I
don't know about if I'm lucky to have a
relationship great but I think I'm
getting to a place where it's a hassle
if it happens great if it's such a
hassle witness but I don't want our
wedding her kids really yeah I don't
think about it I don't feel it in my
heart yeah my harder bones why is that
what we get along so well first of all
yeah everyone in context of if we're
friends or not I'd let the guest do it
cuz I hate it when I go with my cousin
people this is my really good friend
Whitney I'm like bitch I don't know you
why are we pretending to these people we
know each other so I let the guests say
how close we are
well I think we've gotten closer the
past couple years yeah well I opened for
you on the road but I was I feel like in
my 20s very insecure and you I don't
know hmm but I think now or I'm getting
we've spent a lot of time together yeah
and you're like my mentor we're gonna
get into Melissa's impression of me at
some point what is this were you I
remember I feel like I used to be I
don't know I was eating poorly and
dressing real bad
I remember if some shows where I was
dressing weird agree and you're I was
wearing some weird shit these baggy
pants and you're like these are just
like the boys from stranger things I was
just like what is that where is that
from Aldo section she dressed like a
janitor and an Arthur alerts Club and I
was there and you're like okay what is
this don't wear this ever again does
shoes they don't you don't fit you and
then one that the next time we were in
San Francisco and I were like skinny
jeans and some Nikes and you're like yes
where that on stage cuz it just looks
better it like fits you probably feel
better too right
you have you dressed like an Amish
farmer for it like the cuts of your
pants were very like I don't even know
where you're buying me like are you guys
going to Chico's I didn't even know
where you were finding oh gosh my gosh
like I was like where are you fighting
if it was a lot of gap and it's a bold
Navy and they were like bell-bottoms
that were like corduroy I was like is a
taupe corduroy I was like you're so
beautiful and you're such a great body
like what are you worried are you
transitioning I don't know I understand
I don't your gendered call I was like
maybe this is the new gender thing I
don't understand I just I think I go
through wacky day you know I do too I
mean I went and I also it reminded me of
me and I was like I think I know what
you're doing
let me save you a couple years yeah cuz
you yes you dressed like me when I
started yeah hoodies and completely like
try to like neuter myself desexualize
myself yeah I would wear bell-bottoms
like old ratty t-shirts like sports bras
hoodies and like backpacks and sneakers
we both started young and we're both hot
babes no but when I started out 17 going
to haha kephale that my crazy I you know
I was a little I was felt like a little
girl and I felt like nothing about older
men around me and I've had a figure
that's why I my voice is also it
amplified a subconsciously or maybe
consciously I was like I needed make
myself weird so no one attacks me you
know you know I want how honey so I
think I also made my voice this way
that's fascinating I think I did that
with being loud and nasal and being
dirty with my comedy I was like I'm
gonna be as dirty as possible so that I
can find to neuter myself and make my
element like put a shield up so that no
one sexualizes me mm-hmm I know like
it's like a way of degenerate myself and
then I
once something works I remember Neal
Brennan told me this once and I think
it's so true he was like your style
freezes when you get successful cuz
you're subconsciously you're just like
well this is what worked and it's just
the thing that works yes he for the
longest time would only dress like like
street kid from the 90s which was like
exactly how he dressed from the
Chappelle show happened he would still
wear like orange hoodies with like
purple shirt it was like 90s hip-hop kid
and then he just why would you change
something that was working
dude I mean oh yeah I'm saying it's like
oh I think I can change the way a dress
and I'll still be successful it's just
you sort of your brain it's like we're
designed to look for patterns like
pattern right like this right right
right this is what worked inside my hair
in a ponytail onstage it's just like I
wear a ponytail and I can only be funny
if I have the ponytail like I just
subconsciously yeah with the system that
worked mm-hmm you know it makes sense I
feel like I saw you and he's like
bell-bottom and these like weird bounty
hunter Dog the Bounty Hunter shoes and I
was like okay I think she like thinks
she has to do this but she doesn't have
to yeah yeah take the armor off yeah and
now I feel like I've gotten on a good
place on stage where it still could be
tomboy but then there's this bright
color that I could bring to and it feels
like it feels like a costume yeah yeah
yeah yeah it doesn't feel like a costume
anymore yeah I just sort of was like you
know it was a little Tim Allen there for
me yeah yeah I did have a lot of Blazers
too yeah it was very Paula Poundstone
yeah yeah it was very like I didn't know
if it was a character like I was just
like I think this might be like a yeah
thing and we all have our blankies we
all have our thing that makes us feel
safe but I was like I felt something
that would just didn't feel Congress it
was just like yeah oh good she settled
but I think that I also did you feel
like you didn't want to be sexual at all
in the beginning oh yeah yeah yeah well
you've definitely managed to desexualize
yourself
thank those shoes those have to go if
you want that that one-night-stand
you're gonna have to get bender
non-conforming cord awesome Martin's
clogs no corks
what's our clerks Clark's are those like
they were popular you know you're a sec
you know that old lady we're now in the
shoe yes we're like the bulbous front of
the shoe that's what you're like it's
steel toe like a like a like a do you
know I'm saying it was like an Amish
bulbous cartoon shoe the lady that lives
in the shoe shit that actually feels
like my soul though the lady that lives
in the shoe does track that is your
essence friend but that doesn't mean you
can't be alright okay thank you okay
good so okay so that's so we are how
would you define our relationship like
how close are we
I think we're beginning to get closer I
think I think I think it also Melissa's
very literal she's incapable of being
full of shit she will think of the
answer before she just starts mouthing
off unlike most people I think I felt
when we first start like when we first
when I first started going on the road
with you I felt like oh she's Whitney's
up here and I'm down here type of
feeling like I always was a maybe a
little afraid
but now I thought you can't picture you
being afraid of me I think it's just
nervous because I want to do a good job
for your shows and and I I think I was
really in a place of beating myself up a
lot did too good of a job
Melissa would go out kill so hard and
she would go out and kill so hard she
would close with an impression of me
they killed so hard I couldn't follow it
people didn't when I actually came out
it was a letdown because people just
wanted to see her doing you know no no
yes hundred percent but now I think with
my growth and work in life I don't know
I think an experience I feel I
feel closer to you I dick and and yes
and it's not a lot it's just here and
there a couple of them but so let me I
want to get back to the side day because
I donated by this new sort of species of
women that can just sleep with guys and
not be like what's up tomorrow or we
take like well no no I believe there's
always an attachment layer I think so
yes
Utah it's manageable it's manageable
because it's not like if I keep myself
busy I don't know no I get it it's a guy
that you can't see yourself being in a
serious relationship with so you know
where the person stands yes I'm thinking
because I am at 37 years old after being
excuse me I'm burping only in
relationships I'm kind of a relationship
person I go from relationship to
relationship and as a relationship ends
I kind of start the next one and then
I'm always in like I'm either getting in
one getting out of one or in a bad way
like I'm always in tonight see I've been
alone most the time and I've had a
couple of relationships hmm I'm always
in some kind of entanglement and I would
like to at 37 years old have a fair just
two no-strings-attached affair and I
don't know how to go about doing it
without being like so do you live here
now
like to just go like we're gonna have
sex and you're gonna go home and we'll
talk in embrace how do I go about it I
think I'm funny can I say like well
let's get this going hot stuff like my
uncle's 70s I think I do say something
like that okay and I think it's cute
that is cute that's really endearing and
you say it over texts yes okay or
sometimes I slide into direct messages
you initiate oh yeah I because once I
had this to talk with Georgia I was like
Georgia why don't guys ask me out and
she was like well why don't you ask your
guy friends and see what they said
that's such a great joint we all might
pair best I know she's in and I was like
okay fine I'll ask my guy friends why
aren't guys asking me out and they all
Muslim said was like well I think
were intimidated by you he's and it also
appears to seem that you already have
someone at your level like you already
right that's content in that world her
and I'm like no so then once I
understood that I was like oh okay then
I'm gonna do the reach out to uh-huh and
then I would ask you're gonna do the
most intimidating thing I I asked I
started asking there was a spy than last
summer I was like OS came out I last
came out yeah and then they said yes of
course yeah yeah cuz I'm a golden prize
and I'm a treat to have I am so much I'm
cool yeah yeah I got electric guitar I
draw oh but it's but once I realize okay
that I'm gonna do it yes Bonnie
yeah buddy's sick thanks Whitney MOCA so
is that your opening line I draw I mean
that's what I just think of my son like
man I've gotten really cool yeah I agree
you're fucking cat's dead you're a
fucking cat no but I think that for me I
never want to initiate with guys cuz I'm
like oh guys don't want like an alpha
guys want to chase guys are hunters but
even not to be your husband if like with
the fact that we even fucking have to
think that way is so ridiculous I'm like
I need to completely recalibrate the way
that I think about meeting guys cuz for
the longest time I was conditioned to
only go you have to approach this as if
the end game is to be a wife right I
mean but that's probably don't chase
don't do too much be small be cute I
know him rescue you let him sit be
feminine make him chase don't make any
first moves but now they're like if the
goal is just fucking someone
I don't all those were all that goes out
the window I know like I'm at the point
where I'll text like this one guy that
I'm flirting with I'll text him and I'll
beg hey what's up a divide overs about
an hour I'm like hey G over text what's
up I think I don't give a fuck anymore
because if a guy likes you none of that
shit matters I straight up and texting
with this guy that he I will show you
the text wait I don't listen
if you are I could talk about you right
now and if you're into me you'll be fine
with it if you're not right nothing I do
yeah yeah yeah yeah I have no control
over how long or how much you like me I
love I don't give a fuck he's also
thirty good bucket don't give a fuck
okay so he were like texting and I go
onto his Instagram at like 2:00 in the
morning and I'd had a lunesta bad move
and I liked a photo from seven years ago
by accident my thumbs just rusty liked
it and I wouldn't you're gonna leave it
fuck it like the next morning he goes
you are such a stalker who likes a photo
from seven years ago and then I was like
laughing for 40 minutes don't give a
fuck if you want me you want me you're
in or you're out of it and then I talked
about him on the kelly and ryan show did
you just talk about me on the kelly and
other guidance okay if you're into this
you're in that's so cool there's no I
have wasted so much of my life trying to
like construct and shape-shift Inc being
into being the girl that I think you
want based on some social construction I
saw him wear new this is great from an
Heigl movie like I don't even know who
I'm trying to in person now I don't I'm
just gonna do me and you're either in or
you're out
my bills get paid either way woo my bill
to get paid either way and there will be
a guy who is you know yeah down who's
the hottest actor - I mean Javier Bardem
oh all the way okay I like that yeah you
like uh like Michael B Jordan I mean
these that's perfect but also hold on
wait what about Javier Bardem is his so
white guys are off the table for you I'm
done with white guy what happened
time's up times huh yeah what happened
no I know what just besides generally
just being bold just putting sunscreen
on them
I got sick of now I just I'm just like I
don't know
yeah I feel just new new chapter of me
just new pigmentations ahead yeah so is
that a conscious effort like if a white
guy comes out you know yeah I'm my heart
so you'll make an exception for a white
guy yes of course but I but lately it's
been yeah I like black guys
now listen Javier Bardem I actually have
I'm gonna you know what if we're gonna
do this let's do this if you date black
guys I have a warning for you okay
sometimes this is the this is the only
time I was like oh this is a stiffer
--nt fight than I've ever had okay with
a white guy I was in his bathroom and I
personally feel that about four months
into dating someone you're allowed to go
through their drawers that's just my
personal philosophy I went through his
drawers and found you know you'll find
makeup you'll find you know it's just
sort of like a whose is this like you
know is this old is this new you know is
this bath and Bodyworks how old was she
why did you at wedding plumeria bath and
Bodyworks jolt with spar moonlight Pat's
was my favorite in high school well
let's just smell like a path a moonlit
path smells like dirt
earthworms a moonlit path smells like a
fucking rapist in the night what what
why there no it's so good but but
moonlit paths don't have you smelled a
path recently it's fuckin mulch and dirt
and bugs you're making you know being
near you and it's making me tougher
really you noticed this just in right
the six now it's just hanging out right
now energy we're good for each other
it's really good we're good for each
other we bring out good sides of each
other you make me very calm and you when
I'm around you I don't feel like I have
to be funny oh good and I don't feel
like I have to apologize for being
powerful yeah and when you're around me
I think you get stronger Thanks thanks
Whitney
best what was I saying
moonlit Pat disgusting so sometimes
you're in your guy's place and you
you're gonna come across a cosmetic from
a previous relationship and you're gonna
read into it if it's a Victoria's Secret
shimmer you're like he date's strippers
what is you know you're gonna start some
kind of fight mm-hmm or like a guy that
I dated once found makeup in his drawer
and it ended very awkwardly because I
was like who's is this and he was like
it's mine so that's a whole other thing
you could also find out the guy you're
dating uses concealer and that's a whole
other conversation Wow but if you're
dating a black guy there is a chance
you're gonna find jewelry huh and it's
gonna be his and you're gonna have to
believe him but that's cool I know but I
was like oh who's diamond earrings are
those oh and he was like those Mike gave
them back I was like that's not a fight
I've ever had for the white guy so I
stand corrected
so sorry about that here you go and
those are yours
fair enough got it with any white guy
this would be a huge can I borrow I got
a little fucking didn't get the diamond
I know you know the jeweler's number I
know you know the big diamonds but you
got them for yourself enough for me you
should not have better jewelry than me
that reconcilable difference so just get
ready for it that's that's good to know
thanks so so what are we gonna do in
quarantine so we're flirting with guys
are we hooking up no I haven't maybe
early on and this started yeah maybe but
that was it yeah so you have how many
guys in the rotation current oh no just
I mean I guess just one in New York yeah
and it do you date other people or do
get jealous if they or you don't talk
about it that's something I do need to
be careful I need it
be honest Mike are you hooking up with
other people do you want to know
I don't like to I'm finally to putting
my life right don't ask questions if I
don't want to know the answers
it took me a long time where'd you just
go I know I just I just I just went to
you know I don't you know what I like to
think of it as if you're not emotionally
attached to the guy I like to think of
it as he's practicing on his days off
[Laughter]
it's like that you don't want to be in
you don't want to be yeah you sort of
that's when you realize if you're
attached to the person or not you can
say can we exclusively hook up with each
other and if you want to date someone
else you just have to tell me and we'll
call it see that's that's good that's
being healthy I that's what I need to
say yeah I mean that'll have to do I'm
happy to not do the girlfriend boyfriend
thing not my style but I would like to
exclusively be an associate Pathak no
strings attached fuckfest with you
mm-hmm
but you can't do that with anyone else
is that being together that's you're
together
I don't know I don't I still don't know
know anything and so what about the
nudes Howard what are those nudes no no
that was just one reason okay how what
how much new how many are we showing Oh
neck down no face I try to avoid face
cuz of Internet yeah but they can
Photoshop your face on the naked bodies
those are everywhere that's true have
you looked at yours
what no I haven't either I don't want to
see okay I'm just gonna check to see I
the I always get photoshopped onto porn
stars in wedding dresses getting fucked
which is so weird
Oh naked oh it's not gonna come up on
there so if I don't go you know no I'm
just no one's gonna see it except me you
are not photoshopped onto a lot of naked
people I what people do with me is when
I'm holding a microphone on stage they
oh and I'm doing that they put a dick in
my mouth
so I've got a bunch of those that's yeah
that's easy there's no naked photos of
you online at all not even photoshopped
fake ones I've always had always hurts
my feelings the body they choose almost
like that's what they think
darío my boobs are fake don't put some
pancake tip my body in Photoshop I've
worked hard to not have pancake titties
okay so you're only doing neck down and
full naked full everything what are you
handing up in the mirror Wow
standing yeah like with one light out I
think I might pose like it's like at
this in the mirror yes okay because this
is a good one up to down never done Oh
cuz you can have your face in it in a
mirror in a mirror sideways is the my
goat yeah because in the butt is like
the fight is slamming then the waist is
like the ABS okay I'd literally took one
this morning right and offended anyone
the shadow of the light and then your
boobs are good mornings I yeah it looks
really hot yeah
and so what time are you sending these
photos I mean this look this was just a
couple that a couple weeks ago it's a
new person no sim dude well because I
think he's the hottest because here's my
deal is when when you're dating someone
do you want them to see you naked in
person before they see you naked in a
selfie am I allowed to send a naked
photo to a guy I'm dating who's never
seen me naked whoa um I don't think I've
done that before
no once they see you naked you're then
sending it as little tidbits little
snack I'll be like like remember this
yeah yeah I think it's just like after
we've done it then I'm like you know
here's here don't don't forget and do
they send dick pics mm-hmm really I mean
it's it's nice but when I get I like to
see the oh well he's got absent you look
really forlorn over this person I mean
we do ha do you have cabin fever I do
think there is a very intense horniness
bubbling up with like everyone you know
with everyone yes I started flirting
with my bed straight up
straight up I think this cabin fever is
starting to get to us yeah I think so
what is it I I do not enjoy I like
getting dick pics everyone on the show
knows because I like seeing bath
people's bathrooms oh yes but I don't
the actual singing of a dick I'm not let
me use it like I don't that doesn't like
turn me off I I think I'm with you there
yeah but I I sometimes will fantasize
you know but I think that also what
turns me off is not so much the dick
itself it's the taking of that like
imagining the guy being like picking an
angle and like getting it hard and like
like taking five and then picking the
best one like that is unattractive to me
just the process of it Jamie Jim saying
because then he's got like five on his
phone that he didn't send and I know
guys have a good one righty to go I know
that guys have a stock dick photo they
have the little heart should I mean like
yeah and then if you look in the
background you can kind of see clues
it's like is that a like a Ross Perot
sticker in the background you didn't
take that in the last year
why is lost playing in the background
this isn't a new photo this isn't a
recent like guys take one that is like
employee and they save it and they just
send it out good saying I don't think
we're getting I don't think we're
getting new ones every time I think
we're getting custom dick pecs oh my god
you're right don't you think
yeah Whitney you're so smart I really
given this a lot of thought one time a
guy sent a friend of mine a picture of
his dick with another woman's like hand
on it it was a very confusing I think he
liked I think that was like a photo they
shared and he you know but here's a dick
pic and he just didn't see the French
manicured nails around it it was a
bummer it was also a picture of a photo
a picture of oh so yes this was his
photo
yeah this is that Wow what's like your
number one red flag for dudes if a guy
slides in your damn what's the
number-one thing he should not do is it
ask you about work is that I'm an
aspiring comedian is
it yeah I don't like either this you
dated comedians though oh yeah I I'm I
still feel like a comedian might be it
cuz they're just so fucking funny and
that's the hottest thing to me
oh wow interesting and one of the
hottest yeah I just love laughing yeah
yeah yeah it's the best um red flag red
flag wife something oh yeah
kids you want a to go with kids hmm I
guess I did once okay how'd that go Oh a
bit bad huh I mean it didn't work out
well I guess yeah um but I don't know I
don't know my red flags I do I did make
a list like you yeah that was good yeah
that's I made you do that right yeah
good work I make people do lists of all
of their red flags there's a big one
do you remember who they were I do think
a big one with you if somebody has to
like their job I don't care what your
job is but you'll have to light it if
you're not I don't care what your job is
yeah maybe a janitor as long as you love
your job because when when people love
their jobs and someone comes home and
doesn't it's just like it makes things
so hard because you can't commiserate
for sure when someone comes home and
they hate their job I'm like well I had
an awesome day today like I got to
podcast with someone I let like it's
just it ends up sort of making the
relation of toxic yeah I think so people
have to like their jobs the same amount
you can both hate your job or you can
both love your job you know I've never
lived with anyone so I don't know that
but that that is for sure
mm-hmm would be do not want to live with
someone you know I think I would it's
very hard I don't I don't know if I can
do it I've never done I don't know and
I'm gonna have to learn how to share
though share sheriff Mason and think I'm
very um yeah I'm not I'm pretty picky
we're loners I mean comedians are used
to being in hotel rooms eighty percent
of the year alone and like we're good
yeah you know and we can entertain
ourselves are you this way too when
you're when you go on the road the day
before or the day going I'm frustrating
like I don't want to go and leave
I don't want to go and then once I get
there and do the show yeah I don't like
ah that's right I have my fans I can
explore this town find good food
then I'm fine yeah and I get in a groove
yeah it's always that day leaving and I
might be a little fresh you don't like
traveling you like performing yeah
that's what it is that's what I would
say we don't get paid to perform we get
paid to travel
yeah the performing we do for free yeah
I get paid to get on the plane and the
TSA right which I would die don't give
anything to do right now I actually miss
traveling which I never thought I'd say
but yes we actually get paid for and
then when you get in and realize oh I
get to perform for a bunch of people and
make them laugh mm-hmm
you know so I have a question for you Oh
give it have there been hobbies that
you've been I don't know crafting doing
anything during this time being home no
Melissa okay
no any new skills or my brain at all no
my mind is completely atrophied in fact
I've got okay I said the things I'm good
at not only might not learn new skills
here's what I have done I have cooked a
bit oh nice
that's what I should do I'm a pandemic
looking yeah I'm fully now that I don't
think I want to get married I've become
a wife I could cook I can clean I've
been working you know like I have to
write a couple things and I have not
learned new skills but I did get a
mountain bike oh yeah so I'm gonna like
start to like mountain bike that's cool
yeah that's like my new thing and I want
to like get in like sick like crazy like
prison shape like I'm getting in like
like gnarly shape yes and that's really
it and then I'm trying to like work and
read I've been doing the master classes
I've been I've been watching those oh
yeah should I watch some they're amazing
master class fucking fantastic we had
David Sedaris on and I watched his
because I didn't know what it was I was
like it's just something boring it's
like a TED talk like what am i watching
and it's like brilliant people break
down all sorts of things it's super cool
interior design and
science and neil degrasse tyson's is
really amazing like it's just there I
don't think I'd do it if we weren't in
quarantine but I love them it's like
kind of like going back to school that's
a very small kind of yeah cool you've
been what knitting and crocheting and
micro macrame to be honest yeah I I'm a
busy girl yeah I I crochet I draw a lot
I get a lot of I like drawing ideas just
come to me they pop it in my head edible
illustrator and then I um I don't know
yeah I've taken tar lessons let me ask
you what is your I was researching this
before you came in so melissa is you
guys know your is brilliant at
impressions
I'm obsessed because this is a gift this
isn't something you can really I could
never be good at impressions it's not
something I get to work on it's not
something I can pay for it's a gift do
you know yet what the thing is in your
brain that is different because it's
something about your hearing and ability
to mimic because none of us can hear our
voices the way they actually sound so
even if I was good at an impression I
wouldn't be able to ascertain if I was
good or not because we can't hear
ourselves the way other people hear us
so you have the ability you have the
ability to find how you have the ability
to make people hear you the way you hear
you which I can't do does that make
sense no see Melissa will always be odd
as me scientists that have identified
what happens in our brain when we mimic
a foreign accent or impersonate another
person according to a recent study from
the Journal of cognitive neuroscience
the researchers led by all these fucking
people they want to explore the way the
brain controls the nonverbal aspects of
our speech the different tones or styles
people use when talking in different
contexts but but the da da da da da
when when subjects consciously change
their voices either a new accent or in
purse or during a person ation the left
anterior insula an interior frontal
gyrus areas associated with planning and
producing speeches lit up in the fMRI
images impressions in particular
generated greater responses than other
in other regions of the brain
support'll temporal inferior parietal
cortex my goodness I've become
illiterate in quarantine and right
middle anterior superior temporal
succulence Jesus but there was no
difference in the increase in activity
in the LIF G between accent
impersonation planning okay this is like
too hard for me to even understand but
it's something also about your ability
the way your ear is like inner ear is
shaped or something
whoa yeah it's not cool it's me because
we don't know how we sound right and so
for you to be able to do an impression
of whatever it is and then know how it's
sounding and then improve it or know
you're nailing it well it's something
most people can't do like how cuz it's
also you there's no one that's good like
impression is like 90% good it's either
a hundred percent or zero mm-hmm there's
no like that's a pretty good impression
yeah it's excellent or awful yeah yeah
yeah don't I mean yeah and I I think
there's some that like the ones of the
ones where it could really look like
like you or Sarah Silverman or people
like those I could say like those are my
a plus I'm them I see your face on my
face that's what happens in my brain I
see you your your whole face is here
that's what how I see it but if it's
someone like my Sebastian Maniscalco
impression those silly ones they're
they're not exact because I'm not that
good guy but I I I'm learning that
whatever is making me feel funny and
have fun it doesn't that's the key to
impressions also interesting it's like
if I you know just wanna go over here
then it's because I'm I'm having so much
fun that's that is the main thing and
you know that with stand-up so if you're
having so much fun people will just be
into it's also like the level of
commitment but it also works cuz
Sebastian's level of commitment is so
intense I know so almost like to
impersonate Sebastian you just have to
commit as hard to the impression yeah
that's commits to his stand-up yeah like
I just
honest I couldn't like do it like I have
to bail because I get too uncomfortable
I get embarrassed that I'm gonna fail at
it so I just bail but if you love I mean
yeah maybe that's or it is it's some
it's people that I I love so much and I
just I don't know I just want to feel
like they're with me that's so fat
that's like a interesting like spiritual
like element of it that's what yeah I
think you want it like embody them yeah
I think that's a lot of my impressions
are like oh this person brings me like
Owen Wilson brings me some peace you
know just you and that was one of my
first yeah the first time you realize
you can do an impression no no first one
was Britney Spears Christina Aguilera
all the pop princesses of you know don't
worry guys I'm gonna make her do him
don't worry yeah and but yeah I was just
so seeing that I'm a slave for you last
night still a beggar it's so bang bang
oh you people look at me like I'm a
little girl I happen in this world you
get ridiculous so much more than she
would do when you're talking about
who does not feel the need to wash her
hair because I'm obsessed with this dry
shampoo
it's got biotin in it I'm good look oh
god it tastes good too
I am obsessed with this dry shampoo it
is by HASC beauty thank you guys so much
this was incredible
too because it has charcoal in it so it
sucks up all the impurities in your hair
of which I have many look how much cuter
my hair looks when I have this in HASC
is all about second day hair first day
hair is out this is your hair gets cuter
and more textured over time color safe
it's not gonna mess with your color okay
not that I color my hair or anything
I'll have to cover my Gray's cuz I don't
no parabens no artificial colors no
gluten formulated to meet the needs of
your specific hair type and my hair
needs charcoal and biotin and chia seeds
there's one the chia seeds in it that I
love too yeah
oh and it has French on it absorbs all
durable excusive booms so Sophie Sabella
beans husk
dry shampoo collection is available on
amazon.com as well as online and
in-store at Ulta Walmart Walgreens
Target CVS we're very excited to
announce that hask is hosting weekly
giveaways for our listeners who you're
gonna get free hask
you can win a $100 prize that includes
shampoos conditioners leave-in sprays
you're gonna want this one dry shampoos
and more for a chance to win enter the
giveaway at haast beauty comm / Whitney
that's hask beauty.com / Whitney and we
thank them so much for sponsoring this
podcast and making me look my most
sexual self next sexy alright it's a
crazy time no one wants to go to the
grocery store the idea of having to go
somewhere to get your food is the living
nightmare
thank God for daily harvest or else I
would have starved to death about two
weeks ago daily harvest makes it easy to
have clean healthy food without even
trying they send you these like cute
little containers of pre-made food and
as you guys know I cannot cook to save
my life because I just shan't I just I
just can't be a wife to save my life but
harvest is like having your own wife
they send you food that's already put
together like smoothies that are already
mixed like fresh fruits fresh vegetables
like soups it is the only reason that I
do not have scurvy at the moment never
uses preservatives no added sugar no
artificial ingredients they work
directly with farms and they freeze
organic fruits and vegetables at peak
ripeness excuse me peak ripeness I think
that's gonna be the name of my next
special to lock in nutrients and taste
my favorite is the smoothies like they
come like blueberry and greens in it and
everything which I think is the only
reason that I don't totally look like
the Grand Canyon at this point it is so
good and then you just put a little I
put a little bit of like soy milk in it
and then like blend it up that's it
don't have to go anywhere I don't have
to go get germs don't have to go get an
invisible virus I can just stay home and
get my nutrients right from my freezer
it's a goddamn miracle makes me feel
like a human again daily harvest also
committed to minimizing their
environmental impact I love this company
they're in the process of transitioning
to 100% compostable recyclable packaging
and are over 50% of the way there
already and they're good for the
environment this place is amazing go to
daily harvest com enter promo code good
for you and you're gonna get $25 off
your first box that's promo code good
for you for $25 off your first box at
daily harvest com good food is gonna
come to you you don't have to go to it
you just want to go to daily harvest com
have the fresh food come to you keep
that immune system strong folks you're
doing ASMR without water
I'm tricky
so sexual tomorrow always come to China
to me like a like sex always sounds like
sex to me you know no it's just your
mouth like sucking it's like no it's
just you the cotton mouth thing yeah I
don't like it when I you know you're
you're in a car you have a I mean I feel
like going on the road and someone would
pick me up from the airport and yeah or
and they're the driver you can hear em
go or you know just a little sound like
that could just do you oh well you know
what this probably has a lot to do with
the fact that you're good at impressions
you you have some kind of superhuman
hearing that you're able to hear and
mimic people yeah it might have
misophonia which is what I have even
though I'm not good impressions yeah I
mean that's why I was working on a bit
before this about how I think I'm I'm
the trouble in relationships and dating
because I find out the smallest cork
about a person and I go I'm out I don't
do that thing to do that too much
yeah I'm gone are you give it a second
to go could you not do that
is it worth I don't even ask I just
leave uh-huh like whistling don't have
you ever thought about asking them to
not whistle no around you I'm not it's
not I'm not gonna put the whole time in
I
I should have I that's what I I'm a I'm
a coward I I could ask a person kind
like can you just please don't whistle
but I think that would really hurt their
feelings but my guess is you don't like
them that much if that's the straw that
breaks the camel's back that's true and
I also think that things that annoy you
about people you're not that into you
find charming with the ones that you are
into yeah yeah yeah I mean if it was if
Michael B Jordan was whistling in your
hallway you'd be fine right you're right
you're right you would not be like fuck
this I'm at noon whistling really funny
too
I could not imagine my garden was I
can't whistle
that's another plant with that's
probably why I don't like it cuz I'm
jealous
that's you can you're capable that's how
things with your face that no one is
capable of yet you can't whistle
mm-hmm i whistle in no I can't whistle
out I can only suck in down boys mm-hmm
wait because we have horses I had horses
growing up and you had to whistle to get
him to come out so I had to learn I was
so horses were part of your life when
you're little yeah
big part that's so cool yeah when I went
to Virginia in the summers I can't do it
out though yeah I can't blow out you can
do it but that's it I can't do like a
yeah there's like old guys 40s
are you dating Barney Fife like what are
you talking about
you know these guys that are just like
what's so why you didn't change your age
bracket on Gumbel dating podiatrists now
that one what the Whistler was a little
older than me but I think it was more of
a square of a person hmm or just like a
happy joyful man that's all my mom said
- she was like I was like mom he's great
now but I don't like those whistles and
my mom was like yeah I mean it just
seems like a nice man he seems like he's
enjoying life and just sort of going
about his day just make it some music
did you ever tell him that that's why
you were leaving
no there were other elements - that was
like one of the thing yeah it was also
you know yeah but I think that that is
it important because when something that
small bothers you about someone you're
just not into them but he saw my tweet
where I said I don't like these whistles
juice you tweeted back I was like I'm
dating a dude that whistles I can't do
that
and he was and then he saw he's told me
was like you don't like my website of
the tweet do great I mean that's what we
do right you know I come being a
comedian is it kind of like we are
talking shit about everything that truly
everything and if you date a comedian
you're on limits I'm sorry if you're
sucking on limits and I gotta be honest
to you I know a couple comedians that
whose wives would not let them make
jokes about them and their careers
fuckin died there's a lot of really
great comedians out there men and women
whose spouses were like dude you can't
talk about me that's my boundary and
they their careers didn't go or they
show you can't not talk about what's
going on in your personal life and I
always feel bad but it's like that's
just what if you don't want it if you
don't only talk shit about you on
fucking talk shows behave better yeah
like maybe you need to take a good look
in the mirror sir yeah but it is I think
that like you can you don't want someone
that wants to be in the spotlight by
proxy cuz I think a lot of guys are into
that I've definitely had a lot of guys
date me because I think they feel like
there's some clout in it or something
you know I've been star fucked which
just means I'm a star ah but I think
guys that are - look you can't talk
about me it's like why are you gives a
shit no one knows it's you yeah yeah
like why are you saying shell says your
life isn't ruined you're not on TMZ like
and they're just jokes yeah but -
passive-aggressively communicate with
them through Twitter like I mean that is
I think that's more like why did
everyone I was here about it before I
die no you know like you knew he was
gonna read that I didn't know he had a
Twitter and then I saw him following
well that's a bigger problem as you were
dating someone and you didn't know they
were on Twitter you don't ask any you
really don't ask questions you do not
want to listen no I don't so that's my
problem you were fully dating a guy that
in you didn't know he was on a fake
everyone I've dated the past years
especially being honest now it's has
just been like a couple months by couple
months by it's really not it's never
gone past
I think I'm healthy I think that's
healthy yeah cuz I'm just tasting
like such a Sebastian thing is that I'm
just trying to try to different a little
dalip a little dog what when you decide
to do Sebastian impression was there one
bit you focused on I don't think I tried
I think it was you know from doing shows
with him we all do - Sebastian
impression but there was a there's a
there was a sketch that a writer wrote
on SNL it didn't go this show but it
went to table and and he he was like who
should I play have some play Sebastian
and then he was in my writing office and
my friend was like Oh Melissa knows
Sebastian Alyssa could do and I was like
I guess I'll try and then it did so well
and then I was like I realize oh I'm
having so much fun and then and then
it's just like stayed in my heart and I
was like I just want to get this you do
kind of sound like him a little bit just
I mean my voice oh I keep playing around
I think my microphone went out oh it had
fun did it or whatever keep that no I
think I just stopped talking oh here we
go no going around with that I'm so I
think he says you just have to thing
where oh that's it well my voice is deep
to where I can do male impression yeah
yeah like I do it
a John Mulaney on the show no I I swear
there's so many good wait hold on you
have today that is we have to show that
to my jaw Mulaney bit it's him like it's
you know I've done it I share it online
but it's just him in quarantine like
I've noticed I've been spending a lot of
time with my pillows and they are
paper-thin it's like if I told a monster
truck hey why don't you just drive right
over my pillows I want them to feel like
I'm sleeping on a tortilla and they do
and what's funny is the next morning my
wife said hey I want to make some
breakfast burritos and I and she said
but we have no tortillas and I said I
know where I can find one
that's one of my favorite ones to me and
that is fucking amazing
those are been mine I guess the past
year Mulaney Sebastian I mean Billy I
wish I've been doing two for a bit
what's that um very low oh my god yeah
it's like yo I have to take out my
Invisalign because I wearing it but I I
want to eat burritos and tacos and then
she sings like this don't you know I'm
no good for you I've learned to lose who
can't afford that's how she sings cry I
love singing like Billy I love her so
much that bad guy song is maybe the song
around is it weird that she's so young
and I love that song and thinking that I
see it is it's so good
so I remember last time I remember when
you were working on the SIA impression
and just going I think I sent it to her
or gave it to her something and she was
just like how she can hit notes that
most people just can't hit like you can
hit notes it see it Christian Aguilar
can hit well see it I mean I don't think
I did that good one of my favorite songs
is called ritual and the vitamins I take
are also called ritual there's some sort
of symbolism going on here now I am not
gonna lie during this time where we
can't really go anywhere or go to
restaurants or go to grocery stores I've
been eating total garbage and thank God
I take these vitamins there I've told
you about them before they're called
ritual vitamins everybody's asking me
why my skin is so good everyone's ask me
why my hair looks so good
it's not my diet because I'm eating
complete trash but I have been taking
the ritual vitamins and I think I look
amazing just not gonna lie
ritual essentials has the nutrients most
of us don't even get from food anyway oh
so I can keep eating trash clean
absorbable vitamins no shady additives
no weird ingredients that do more harm
to your body than good quite frankly too
easy to take capsules provide 9news
treants you need to support a strong
foundation for your health which we all
need right now more than ever from d3 to
omega-3 ritual essential for women helps
fill in the gaps of your diet no nausea
capsule doesn't make me sick
it also has omegas in it and normally
when you take other fish oil pills
you're like burping up Worf for the rest
of the day and you just like smell
permanently like clam chowder ritual has
a little like mint in it so that you're
not like you know smelling like Wharf
inside your mask you know I'm saying
you're welcome gentle on the stomach the
little mint tab and every bottle to keep
things fresh so you don't have that
fishy aftertaste I was talking about
vegan friendly sugar-free non-gmo
gluten-free and allergen free
ingredients there's no trash in here
okay the subscription is easy to start I
also love it because you subscribe to it
and just comes to your door because for
me I always forget to order vitamins and
I run out and I'm like a half by the
time I order it I'm probably gonna have
scurvy anyway so I might as well just
stop taking it ritual it just comes to
you so you don't have to think about it
all the time better help does not happen
overnight and right now ritual is
offering my listeners 10% off during
your first three months fill in the gaps
with your diet with essential for women
get that skin on point get their hair on
point get those nails on point get every
of get that get that stuff I might love
to say shit in an ad get that shit tight
you know what I mean people keep asking
me when my skin I'm telling you this is
why it looks really good right now
a small step that it's gonna help you
support a healthy foundation for that
body visual visual I try to say visit
ritual and I just said visual visit
ritual Tom slash Whitney to start your
ritual today 10% off turn your first
three months at ritual dot-com slash
Whitney don't be ridiculous
also someone send these to chris d'elia
cuz he looks like shit actually I will
if he if someone orders ritual vitamin
if someone orders a ritual vitamin
prescription for crystal Leah you have
to go to ritual calm slash Whitney
tagged me and say you're ordering
vitamins for chris d'elia but actually
order them for yourself i will repost
you
yeah and then Christina Aguilera has she
seen yours yeah you know what she did
that not too long ago she found some old
vine of mine where I was doing her and
she she reposted it and that was like I
didn't look good and I was like she's
like this is so me and I was I saw it I
was like oh why'd you ditch what's that
one I looked so bad there but it was
that was nice of her um yeah you know
see it
I just yes I have a bit you see my see a
bit though yeah but I go don't get hurt
can't feel anything when will I learn I
bullshit bullshit uh-huh I'm a wonderful
good I love her voice it's so I knew
she'd never had voice training like she
never like took that yeah yeah that's
where I sometimes want
I do want vocal training but then it's
also like why mess it why just why not
just leave the gifts yeah leave them
leave them alone which is one that you
like like wish you could go and you're
like okay critics ariana grande I really
want to learn her singing voice but
she's got it I mean that's it's
incredible voices because it goes so
high yeah but it's also it's like Mariah
to where it's like there's a lawyer it's
low but it's also high at the same time
and I don't know it's hard to get mm-hmm
so Mariah's is probably hard oh yeah who
are like the top three voice I could
kind of do a little Maria I mean I'm
showing off here it's quarantine time
will Islam behave for a moment in time
and a cinema lasting that you would
always be mine
and now you wanna be free so I'll let
you fly because you know I'm a heart
babe
love will never die no I'm sure now you
have your showboat that's what I was
thinking tears like you know just
entertain that's all people it's just
some joy
it's it what right now I think here's my
deal whatever pill is peddle it yeah
this is what people do now they get
famous for a skill and they go now I'm
gonna do something else it's like no
bitch that's what we've paid you for I
know that's where I've only I've had
that little battle tour I'm like I don't
want to do impressions but it's like
that's just Hawaii yeah but what know
what oh you're gonna go do the thing
everyone else can do yeah I know I mean
it's ungrateful yeah yeah it's ungrate
it's ungrateful or you're saying fuck
you to God yeah and it's frankly rude
yeah you're right I just I died there's
this new thing where it's like you know
people will be really funny or they'll
get really good at comedy they're like
but now I want to do drama it's like
bitch just do the thing ray I know why
yeah you know I think there's some like
weird shame I mean I did it to wear this
new special I'm doing it just as like a
challenge myself I'm like I just don't
want to talk about sex in it or like
just cuz I've done that a lot and it's
just like a little challenge to myself
yeah you know and I'm I have had a
couple people be like ah like I came
with my girls night and we you know and
I do sort of feel like okay when people
come see me there's a certain thing they
do expect and I don't want to disappoint
anybody because of my own personal goals
of evolving but you you're saying fuck
you to your audience I mean yeah that's
why I felt now when I want to get to do
stamp I look I just want to balance it
all in it I could still talk about
myself or my family and my and and then
also weave those impressions in so
there's a nice like it's just feels
balance so that way I'm happy but I'm
also yeah making me proud happy did you
talk to Sara after you did the
impression of her when
did you do it on a snow oh yes here so
me yeah yeah yeah yeah she loves it
every time if I run into her at a club
she's always like that's old one too so
crazy though
I know which one is more is she more
Sarah or is her impression of Sarah
better or sort of person me better I
don't know I mean it's like saying fuck
you to God I mean I hope you always like
always I love you so much I feel like
it's like a sister to you know but when
it actually truly was when sigh I don't
know how else anyone else could you know
go experience this it's maybe like the
one positive side of like being a known
person is that it is really nice to see
yourself reflected and you're able to go
like oh yeah I shouldn't do that like
it's the only way I'm able to receive
criticism in a way without getting
defensive like like when Instagram
stories first started I had no idea what
we were supposed to be doing like we
were all just like hey guys I'm having I
had some water like once I'm meeting my
knots like I was like every supposed to
be funny or was supposed to be like like
literally documenting every second of
our mundane boring lives like I have no
idea and she just did one that was like
it really made me change the way I did
Instagram story you made me see how
fucking boring mine were and you're just
like um I guess I don't need to do an
impression myself like I just like when
you and when you uh when you always when
you do your skin care routines to you
know you just we're gonna roll some oil
here that helps the glow and I'm just
gonna do that for a couple hours
hey guys it's my roll roller it's funny
because what I try to do a depression of
huge
listen to me I try to do impression and
I don't I can just talk but you're like
so guys like in the car oh yeah that one
for two hours like does it go bad drink
it or not like let me know let me know
cuz I'm gonna drink it everyone was
dying because just like like annoyed I
am question I just asked you guys my
dude like what I was Lu why am I so
pissed off
that's just like one time like sometimes
don't post it cuz theres like anyway let
me know like I got bored making the
story made me realize that I would get
bored doing it I think oh guys did all
the new stories that I'm entertained by
now you can do anything it made me it
made it clear to me that I was like
voting it in because that I was hate
fucking my Instagram story no yours are
great hmm you have a lot of good stuff
too all the animals oh yeah it's too
many animals I gotta take it down a
notch you I feel like are doing a lot of
different things over quarantine let's
tell everybody all the stuff that you're
doing you're doing YouTube lives like
every oh no no no I just did no no no I
did I was doing up Melissa hobby time
uh-huh
Monday through Friday okay and it's like
Monday I would do polymer clay I have
clay and I make figurines oh cool
Evan and I bake them okay it's just fun
it's not what murders are you it's not
it's what stable people do I swear I'm
doing okay I mean with just the Hobby
system as a woman with a full life she's
not marrying you she's got her figurines
that she puts in the oven Tuesdays oh I
was doing like a Owen Wilson meditation
where you all through a meditation as I
had well yes yes and then Wednesday
that's on your Instagram mm-hmm these
are like Instagram lives I took this
week off just for my own peace peace
Wednesdays is bird-watching which I
would draw a bunch of birds color them
place them around my home and bird watch
and learn about him and I would set the
cup there sounds of what they sound like
and then go oh there was one oh and then
you know and then I had Fred Armisen
came on and Kevin I mean uh oh Michael
Rapaport and they're and they're just
like oh shit look at that bird and it
was just like a little drawing you know
and it was so that's been fun I think
people that wasn't one of my favorites
amazing and that my sister came up with
that idea I was like just drawing
because you can't really leave home not
good too you know and so Thursdays
that's really crocheting and I've
noticed like all crochet and and karaoke
sing songs and then and it's a like
strong it's very soothing
yeah it's you like and I like hobbies
where there's a result at the end and
proof that I did it yes Jay seems very
rewarding it is here's the scarf and
it's just so it's in your in my mind
like I'm just hearing one uh one two
three one two three it's just a good no
it's like almost meditative yeah notic
yeah I like that it's really cool yeah
teach you there's I mean I'm a visual
learner so I can't like read
oh here's the crochet pattern I don't
like it that's why I struggled in school
I can't read it
I need a visual I need to see someone do
it and then I'm like I got it
yeah I'm done I get it fast when's your
birthday October 9th Libra ooh I don't
know I don't I don't know anything I
don't I'm just curious okay
I feel like horoscope people listening
at that moment wanted me to ask okay
yeah so tell us what that means yeah cuz
you know my theory about it is not that
there's some sort of like supernatural
thing I think that where your birthday
falls is very important in the way that
your psyche develops more because of the
other holidays you're competing with
during your birthday mmm you know what I
mean Halloween I've talked about this
part yeah if you're competing with
Halloween you're gonna get less
attention on your birthday
my birthday was the first day of school
which set the stage for you work all the
time even on the days that you're
supposed to get attention everything is
about
you know people that are born in January
capricorns are always like not needy
like work a lot because there's no money
left to throw them they had just had
holidays Christmas yeah no one's that's
my brother and my mother one is special
if their birthday is January 5th no one
cares
we just party for - we haven't don't
have any money left here's a fucking
regifter vac and all I think October
early October that's kind of a good
birthday time I think so too it's a
little bit after September like yeah
just got back into school yeah but it's
like this holidays are coming
yeah and then now it's and you're just
feeling a little like like like Leo's
everyone says like people born in late
July August or like you know
narcissistic and need a lot of attention
like because it was August like they
could have a party they were like at the
beach like there was no competition from
school like people wanted to have their
last like rum spring up before school
was back you know like so I feel like
that's really why the horoscopes matter
so that's why I'm curious when people
are born just based on when they
celebrated their birthdays yeah not so
much about like sad shit yeah and then
what are you doing Friday's drawing
drawing is that on Instagram life yeah
so you're doing Instagram lives everyday
yeah but this is impressive I mean I
don't know it helped once I just said Oh
today it's gonna be at ten minutes
today's could be twenty it doesn't need
to be an hour you know once I just said
I took the pressure off but do you were
speaking people comment don't keep your
face I know it was so cute come back
sorry we're now just fully taking
pictures of this dog cuz this is the
cutest thing ever
can you hear this okay well I'm gonna
let you go soon but I'm gonna do a
little speed round of stuff okay
that's because what she didn't pee or
anything right she's a good girl I don't
think so I'm sorry okay so we are going
I'm gonna do a look speed around of a
couple things I asked everybody okay
which is very important okay what is the
best piece of advice you've gotten this
show we want people to turn it off and
be better
people smarter people stronger people
more emotional resilient people this
show has a purpose so I always like to
disseminate everybody's best piece of
advice that they've gotten okay a couple
things doesn't okay I'm not gonna make
you pick not a dick um like just about
relationships about like I'll do all me
to list mine while you're think I mean
yeah that helps but I think that from
what you just said earlier about being
with someone that at least likes their
job and I think that's a really good um
good one cuz I for the longest time I
was like oh if he doesn't like his job
I'm just gonna make up for it by being
funny and entertaining and like I'm
gonna help us find a new job and like I
kind of like that he's miserable cuz
then I'm the light of his life like I
just was like God it took me I just wish
someone had told me that when I was like
yeah you know it's if someone's
miserable with their job they're
miserable
yeah that's up to ya there's no way
it took me a long time to process this
piece of advice but when I heard it it
was it's an incredible piece it took me
forever to implement it but someone said
it's not about the other person it's
about who you are when you're with the
other person so a lot of times in
relationships were like is he is he
honest is he fun
is he interesting and he's he this is he
that instead of me when like Who am I
when I'm her am I the best version of
myself when I'm around that / yeah am i
being funny and I've taken care of
myself am I being interesting am I being
the best you know what I mean instead of
putting it all on them and the scorecard
being on what they're doing like what am
i doing what am I am i sleeping well am
I like seeing my yeah yeah I you know
prolific at work am I like that was a
huge paradigm yeah I think for me it was
like oh if I'm if I feel any anxiety
near this person go bye-bye run not
butterflies not passion it's your body
telling you get out of it yeah cuz then
I put them first and yeah I saw your gut
is telling you turn around yeah and we
do were so disconnected from our
intuition at this point I think you
might have said that somewhere I don't
know yeah I do yeah yeah my wisdom
advice from you I'm serious yeah
no I don't I believe it I really I agree
yeah you know I mean I feel no it's good
I felt I've had lots of good
breakthroughs together yeah because I
think for me as soon as I learn
something I think have to tell it
sometimes I worry that I'm coming off
bossy or micromanage II or didactic but
I'm just like oh my god like it would
have saved me so much other people too
I'm an energy let me just pass this off
even this person thinks I'm annoying or
like even if they're not even gonna hear
it yet yeah I feel like a moral
obligation to pass it on that's because
I for the longest time thought a pit in
my stomach meant it was like he's the
one you know app in my stomach was like
look we have so much passion like we're
soul mates like like it was like no this
is your body telling you to get the fuck
out of there yeah you know I think that
like where I understand now that
relationship should calm you down and be
additive not subtractive and not
adrenalized you and stress you out you
know like you can have like a fun hot
affair but like you know that adrenaline
becomes addictive and then yeah addicted
to a person that you don't like that
much that shouldn't be in your life
it's a nightmare and then like all the
neuro chemicals start firing and then
you're addicted to somebody that you
can't there's nothing worse than being
like I don't even like you but I'm on my
way over
it's yeah such a motherfucker get out
before you get addicted it's like seeing
the whatever yeah I take a bite of the
pizza you'll never stop eating it yeah
take that first I didn't like when I had
those relationships where I would I
remembered them ending the break-up and
I would I forgot after I was like Who am
I cuz I got so wrapped up in the person
I felt felt like I lost myself was like
where's Melissa Jesus I'm talking like
he talks I don't have I'm not talking
like me but that's that's the problem
too is as an impressionist if I'm around
someone so much I'm starting to mimic
them I'm absorbing everything and it is
so hard sometimes when you get in a
trench relationship like that to know
when you begin and they end and where
you went and they began and that's what
is a healthy sexy fun relationship where
you still have our
not like you know your surgically
detached from each other as well how do
you mean learn about my posture no
please I feel like the mic has been I
feel like I was like this alot of time
but you could still pick me up this way
yeah I should stayed like that we very
fancy microphone I know so we both talk
incredibly loud as well I'm gonna think
I'm sure things will pop up in my mind
later for advice no but I think that
it's basically it I'm really interested
in this because I think people are right
now in quarantine with their others
where I imagine it's like actually
physically hard to tell where they and
and the other person begins but it is
really hard to maintain your own
identity when you're in a relationship
and I just think it's really important
that people remember you are allowed to
be different than your partner you're
allowed to like different things you're
allowed to want different things you're
allowed to like dislike different movies
I'm now at the point where in the
beginning of a relationship
people think I'm coming off
confrontational or like being like sassy
or bit but I just want to be so clear
about the things I don't like so that
they know like cuz I would just
shape-shift people like I love murder
documentaries that make me Joe I don't I
don't
some of them but like you know what I
mean I pretend I like something I didn't
like and then I had to sort of perform I
had cast myself as the perfect mate for
this person pretended I liked a bunch of
things I didn't like and then six months
in you start getting resentful cuz
you're always acting and then you're
actually having to watch hockey or
whatever the fuck you pretended you
wanted to like and then you get
resentful and then it's like you don't
understand me it's like no it's not that
the person is understand you you just
lied all that time and I think that a
lot of times when we think that we're
just like being harmonious and like
getting along and compromising we're
actually lying you're being a liar it's
not nice or Noble to pretend you like
shit you don't like no I'm suddenly one
of the guys I'll just go have wings yeah
I love watching football like you're
doing a lot you're a liar like you're
blyer it's not cute it's not sexy yeah
one of the guys like it's just like a
it's just a he can handle you not liking
some of the things he likes no Jamie
probably we got the biggest fight over
marriage story this guy that I'm
flirting with and I just was like if I
don't say that I don't like this movie
I'm gonna have to watch it again so I
just like be straight up about it and be
like here like and they're like well why
are you so conversation I'm like no I
think this is just me literally telling
the truth a lot of times girls pretend
they like think they don't like because
we've been wired to believe that you
guys can't handle disagreements and then
you interpret it as like a rejection do
you I'm so worried about your ego that I
don't want to criticize anything that
you like yeah we've been wired to just
make it no I totally love rugby yeah I
remember when I was dating that one guy
you know around yeah we were in Aspen
and I I'm already I'm are no no no
already feels right your are no no no
it's already bad place with no oxygen no
yes you are t nobody was like giving the
option like maybe we could ski or
sending it off I said no cuz my kneecaps
they're bad kneecaps point both of them
yeah I've had inflamed kneecaps
oh I it was a real hard time for me to
walk no from so anyway and too much no
no this was a few years ago I don't know
what happened I don't I'm not sure how
they but something went bad in my knees
and I had to go through physical therapy
and have tape on my kneecaps for a few
months because they couldn't I don't
know what happened so I don't mess with
that stuff but I was almost gonna agree
to skiing never done in my life oh no
you have a broken shoulder from
snowboarding yeah no I don't I don't
like that stuff broke my shoulder
because I didn't want to tell a guy like
you I'll just stay here
oh yeah I remember reading on your book
I'll just stay here you go have fun
we'll see each other in like four hours
yeah no I don't like that stuff if a guy
stay inside and read and smell stuff I
mean smell books or things what I'm just
saying I want to be inside or in that
garden I don't want to go do something
adventure if you do need a woman that
like goes down the slopes with you like
I just you you know I'm saying yeah
if you can't handle being away for four
hours from your woman and her not having
the same skillset as you think I mean
sunny of sunny and she is dead oh man
into a tree what are we doing why is
anyone ever skiing no skiing is also if
you're not asking you grew up rich like
you can't just all of a sudden have
grown up rich like if you didn't start
skiing at five it's not happening yeah
cuz you're close to the current gray and
it's all three grand just to try it it's
like I'm not willing to put in the
invent I went to go snowboarding it's
like the shoes and the clips and the
hats and the shit in the fucking shit
it's just like I there's no way it's
this fun I knows no way it's worth
$3,000 that's so weird
I just want to just give me a little
sled sit on it nothing fun it more fun
than a narrative yeah nothing more I
remember that why do we have to bring
sharp giant daggers and put them on each
of our feet like what are we do is this
shit even legal
they're giant knives and we're going 80
miles an hour with no brakes call it
good yeah skiing is what wild that's
gangs cancelled times up on skiing why
would anyone ski can you imagine
think about it if someone if skiing
didn't exist and someone came up with
the idea today jail it'd be the fire
festival of sports did you bring a
ballet about that or something I have a
whole bit about okay yeah yeah yeah yeah
I think I saw that I do that my new hour
that's so fun I talk about ballet for a
good 15 minutes yes and how I think it
should go yeah yeah it's gotta go the
sickening you guys will see that when
we're back on the road in six years yeah
and then I also I went out the best way
if you think of any other advice like
since you are now on SNL and you're now
so fancy have you learned anything about
like money since you started making it
that you think that people in their 20s
would benefit from hearing well I think
saving is always good I think I've
always been a saver what do you spend
money on that works where you're like
that was worth it I buy a purse I feel
worse I don't
better I don't buy material things I'm
my problem I'll buy little hunk things I
ya know I like you know sometimes I'll
buy like today I was gonna buy a garden
gnome this morning stuff that's I guess
that makes me happy but it's weird but
um I think look I just got my first law
my townhouse that was an investment
buying real estate and spending money on
your space is key
yeah investing in your space don't buy
the shoes buy the fucking coffee table
yeah I didn't I don't know I'm not the
best with I just I'll save but that's
good um that's good what's the best gift
you've ever got but I was gonna also say
I think now having one more like I save
but I also I donate and I think that it
feels that it's awesome because I mean I
Trey yeah awesome but I mean bits like
that that it should go out I don't know
yeah that's awesome
and you get a tax break donating your
skin the pay less taxes later yep you
can be selfish and benevolent at the
same time yeah and then but I spoiled my
penny yeah a lot of dogs
yes that's key yeah dog doc get a duck
duck you're a loner a person yeah and
you're thinking too much on shoes and
the purse get a adopt a dog yeah that is
going that that's a big one yeah that
should my life it's not cheese if you're
gonna need day care and people to help
you walk right but I thanks but I do
look at like this past couple years
Oh what year no with penny yeah I I
don't feel that missing piece of lacking
something to care I didn't have them
someone to care for yeah like us we want
to care about something we want to love
something we want that unconditional
love bond but people are the worst so
dogs are like the perfect level of like
okay this is not because even like I
need to give I need to love things but
when I do that with people or try to
rescue people it just blows them in my
face yeah dogs actually I see that they
actually appreciate the love you give
them it doesn't chase them away and
they're capable of unconditional love
but they keep you warm at
night what more do you want feel so cozy
with her it's so funny I'm always the
breed of dogs people get or the kind of
dog they get to me as always so
fascinating and penny your dog it's I
think she's my guess is she's like a
whippet lab yeah for sure which is so
perfect for you yeah yeah and it's so
what's funny about penny is she has a
really worried
eyebrows in face you're like that - yeah
you are the epitome of joy and
spontaneity and fun and buoyancy but you
there's also a think a little bit of yes
warrior thinking and a good way in a
good way how was dave grohl manis like
he told the story about how he went he
got stoned he took an edible by accident
and went to like John Lennon's house or
Tom Lennon whatever the guy for the
Beatles and Taylor Swift was like
singing a song he was so high until she
was like singing a song and he said what
song is that and she was like ever long
like it was like his like he was so high
that he didn't even not like just he
just tells stories and such a funny I'm
so obsessed with because that maybe you
hang out something there like I'm
waiting for that yeah I want that and
that's what I'm talking about if you
were pivoting hard here if you could
date any celebrity right now who would
it be I think it would be like Dave
Grohl yeah well he's married but yeah
but you're like if they weren't because
my thing is I do think mm and I should
date oh do you think I've been talking
about a lot on the pot oh oh I want to
do Shia LaBeouf he's I think married now
and I think Shia is not well a lot of
work yeah I think he's very brilliant
but I think that would be a lot oh I
think it would just maybe too intense I
think so I think like I can you actually
like to show idea you want someone chill
you don't need an extra drama in your
life SNL is like oh like it's a radio a
big work thing you know like we have big
emotions in our jobs there's a nice
takes it's very intense I don't think we
want that on our person no no no we want
her song blanket you know like Eminem
yeah yeah why a man him I just feel like
Eminem and I would get along very well
he talks about his addiction stuff I
know a lot about it I'm in a program so
we would connect on that level I feel
like he is like comics and rappers are
pretty similar and you know I mean just
in terms of you're not just a we hold
that hold that you saw me blink yeah you
did you just I did I didn't hear what
you said right now what happened I don't
know I don't know just tuned me out I'm
sorry yes what do you but what do you
think happened I don't know you get
bored I yeah I don't even know where I
went this happens a lot okay so and and
people know now you notice that yeah no
you just went somewhere oh my god you're
just like you just what okay starting
starting at doll starting face your eyes
did you most people just let that slide
oh my gosh how do you and what's wrong
you you're very no it's people that
observant are good plan I don't this is
John Dewalt knows this about me that
Allison they know that that's for good
friends that when I'm hanging out they
they can tell when it this happens yeah
but nothing happened in my head but so
you just play with it you're just like
yeah yeah we just keep going uh-huh
uh-huh and then yeah being a wired but
then and I'll go so what do you think
I'm screwed then I really have to disc
well I think why not and then you
fucking your charm on and have an
impression and then no one fucking calls
you on right that's how that's what I've
done a lot of my last rack yes you so
this is this sure this charm thing is a
total maladaptive behavior it's a
manipulation like I just
this is if I wanted someone to tune me
out I'd hang out with a man I wouldn't
hang out with you I would add you I
would you I thought you would listen to
me so how long is the blood
I don't know that was a couple seconds
huh mm-hmm where do you guide you go it
just you go nowhere it's just I'd rather
be anywhere but here no no it's not even
that my brain just just it kind of just
slowed down mm-hmm and it maybe it's
like a lack of food or something oh yeah
maybe you have low blood sugar
I do okay a little bit all right we have
to get you to eat but I I do think
dating Eminem would be good for me
I do feel like you could date I wish I
think Tom Hardy's not single
I feel like he'd be good for one of us
today mmm mmm you want someone like
chill who's like doesn't talk a lot
write a giant black tie all right now I
think it's someone who's gonna enjoy
silence all right one of my favorite
things is just sitting next to friend or
person and we're both working on
something I'm just having Tampines
gather why it is the best it's so nice
that's to me is like the ultimate
intimacy yeah we've done that before
outside we've done that we're just
saying like this
yeah just staring let's work together in
totally different places it's the best
and then when you do feel like you can
check in at any moment but nothing feels
like a rejection it's not like are you
mad are you there's no pressure to
perform yeah I would love to find that
because I do think that we're in a time
this quarantine thing is I think we're
all gonna come out with less friends
because the people that we didn't want
to catch up with over the break you're
gonna realize that we didn't like them
that much in the first one like I just
were friends with you because I saw you
every day I work mm-hmm
you know I'm not gonna like zoom with
you mm-hmm you know there's a lot of
people I'm like oh that was like a
proximity friendship we were really only
friends because I didn't have a choice
is Brad Brad Pitt single he is single I
think I I would go for bread pit well
that is a hot take that is a hot take
she's willing to make an exception for a
white guy Brad I do that we got a
manifest session okay this is my Brad
Pitt impression you know how
uh what's his name - Chanel what's his
name
nope Josh Duhamel Josh Duhamel married
Fergie because he talked about her on a
talk show anyway so let's put that out
there can you have a brad pitt
impression yeah okay it's real silly -
okay you know he does that in
Inglourious he's well now what we're
gonna do is I'm gonna have I'm gonna see
my own oh if I go see my friend Joe over
there wave hi to Joe if you don't listen
to him Joe over here is gonna shoot your
eyes out okay I can't remember I did a
video I got a I got a reposted I've no
knows that it's like it you're gonna get
that like slow like he's been doing that
in the past like Tarantino films where
he's just alright
what do you say we have that dinner but
I love Brad I mean I feel like he's
really he's grown and I think his if
he's a beautiful spirit he's a beautiful
spirit he talks openly about getting
sober mm-hmm and and that one article I
think he was like I'm just so sick of
hearing about myself
he was like sick of him that's hot but
that's no but are you doing an interview
as you pose for a mountain shirtless oh
man he's great I know he's great and
he's it's interesting like he's one of
the few people that have stayed famous
and stayed love beloved and he like went
there so famously yeah you know and we
still love him can't stay mad at you
Brad he's one of those I can't stay mad
that's when you know you that's my
definition of love by the way you can't
stay mad no one's gonna get mad it's
just can't stay mad mm-hmm we don't stay
mad at Brad Pitt no no we don't stay mad
at Jen we don't stay mad at Mel Gibson
apparently
we don't stay mad oh I don't know
there's a lot of people about Mel yeah
he's just like publicly did some wild
shit and we like we're like Braveheart
yeah I can't stay mad at you yeah you
called your wife a whore for like 40
minutes on a voicemail it's fine boy
yeah well yeah I say Brad Pitt though
okay anything else
I'm just we need to cover thanks for
having me and I love you Whitney I love
you so much this is fun we're gonna like
spend more time together over the corn
game yep anything yeah what do you think
is me over
it's your gut tell you June you think
June you they were to be back in clubs
and no person to I don't think well you
think okay that's yeah I think that'll
be next year I just want to share one
stye don't know exactly don't that
happened to me I went to coffee bean I
hadn't gone in any places but I was
going to see my mom in a nursing home
and she can't leave right they're locked
in um I was gonna Brett brought her some
coffee right so I go to this coffee bean
no one's in there most of it is the
drive-through Starbucks right so it said
no service without a mask I had gloves
and I have my mask and I go in and the
woman has her mask i order the coffee
and the gymnastics that went on like the
choreography that was already kind of
like implicitly known between the two of
us so she rings it up steps away I
waited till she stepped away I leaned in
I did my credit card like this mm-hmm
stepped away she made my coffee and when
she handed me my coffee I was six feet
away from her she put it down kind of
pushed it backed up then I stepped
forward and took it like it was such a
complicated set of moves that we
implicitly do and I just was like that
that was so complex like whenever you
get back back to a place where someone's
I mean a comedy club and just take a
drink from a waitress and put it in
their mouth I mean
that's what our job is our job is for
people to walk into a dark place with a
thousand people and just take a drink
from a stranger and put it in their
mouth like it's like when are we gonna
get back to that comfort level you know
I'm sure there's gonna be officer it
will be the vaccine in the antiviral but
it's just do you remember when we used
to just take a glass from a person whose
hands we don't even know how many people
touched it who touched it and just put
it in our mouths in the dark
shoulder-to-shoulder with thousands of
people who are exhaling for two hours
and oh yeah that's what performing as a
comedian is and then you're asking
people to like breathe on each other and
then you're also asking them to not
think about any of that
like I think music you'll be able to go
to a music festival and be like we have
our outside we can have our masks and
but for us it's like loose I mean comedy
we're asking people to also be at their
most carefree yeah so my question was
like even if you are gonna be open the
doors even if people are gonna come are
they gonna be in the mindset where they
feel like they can just forget you're
asking people to forget about their
problems and is everything gonna be a
little reminder what's the thing and the
put into this and the put and the the
bill and the bill comes in the pen and
what pen do I use in the in the where do
I put my jacket and this person or that
person or you're talking someone coughs
is a show over when someone coughs is
everyone thinking about that all of a
sudden yeah you're right it's gonna
might take a while it's just even if you
can't open the doors are people gonna be
emotionally ready is it gonna be an
environment conducive to comedy I also
feel like it because as I touch my face
I know I touched and after I washed
yeah I'd feel weird to be like come to
my show let's sell out I don't want to
do that for a new tent and no yeah it
feels more like a little weird wrong cuz
it's also a lot of people live with
their parents or grandparents or visit
you know what I mean like I think that
when you live in LA or New York we're so
disconnected from families like a lot of
people like go see their grandma every
Sunday or go see their mom on the
weekend like you know their mom takes
care of their kids like it's not just
about young people interacting with
young people yeah you know so it's just
this weird thing where you know our job
is asking people to get in the room
Just Breathe all over each other this is
where it just gets devastating and this
is where this is where this is the last
thing I want to say is that us
performing and stuff right now it's been
interesting like I did an Instagram live
with your buddy Cecily strong yesterday
and like we were kind of funny but it's
it's this weird time where I never know
if I'm supposed to be being funny and
silly like as being silly disrespectful
like it's this weird time where what's
funny is changing I think something
that's so great about you is like
there's this kind of corona proof energy
like like you're not talking about
things that are charged you're not
talking about politics like just like
any time someone goes to your page you
know it's gonna be fun you know it's
gonna be like effervescent and buoyant
and it's not you know a lot of my
favorite comedians I'm like I love you I
just don't want to watch you talk about
coronavirus for 45 minutes right now but
you know I mean yeah all your comedies
about that like everything's political
like I kind of want to break from that
right now yeah yeah yeah I'm getting to
a point right I only look at the news
once a day cuz I'm just like I cannot
keep just putting this shit in my veins
all day yeah it's it's too depressing
and I can't stay funny if I'm just like
consuming this constantly yeah you know
me too
so I think it's important that was like
we make sure that but it's it's just
weird because it's like there is this
line like I don't wanna be disrespectful
but I also want to make sure that I'm
staying funny like it's just like an
interesting time to see how comedy is
gonna evolve right now you know yeah and
I think that's why I'm just leaning into
things that bring comfort for me yeah it
will hopefully bring comfort to others
yeah but that's what I'm trying to do
but yeah it felt weird once this started
happening I was like oh I don't care
about my dreams and goals I just I just
want to yeah it's just so shifted a
giant paradigm shift happened like
especially I think for ambitious people
where I just was like I think it's a
little thing called perspective I think
we all got it real quick especially
overachiever types where's like oh
nothing really matters the way we
thought it did yeah all of a sudden but
I think that for people that are
overachievers especially the fact that
other people aren't achieving anything
either helps us be able to be like okay
we don't have to compare and despair
with other people right now either
because they're not doing anything
jeanna mean mm-hmm we never would have
been able to take a three-month break
while other people were generating stuff
right yeah but yeah it is really
interesting how the existential crisis
came in real fast like nothing matters
I'm just gonna draw birds yeah yeah but
there is an interesting of like time to
experiment like Who am I when I'm not
doing things out of obligation Rushing's
like Who am I like it's been an
interesting question that I feel like
hopefully all of us will be more
developed interesting people after this
I do think in terms of comedy we will
all be worse at comedy yeah because we
haven't done it for a year but we will
have more interesting things and more
introspective things to say yeah though
we will be very rusty but I think we'll
be grateful to be like back on stage
like oh yeah I don't feel nice can't
wait no I love you very much
Melissa Instagram just your name right
Melissa V comedy well that's a V calm
and put it in Instagram and don't write
elephants subscribe to the YouTube
channel I don't know this shit the bed -
normally says and I know I have to say
it but I just subscribe
you know it's you're an adult you know
what to do I love you guys I always on
this very awkwardly Melissa Villasenor
is the best around nothing's gonna ever
keep thanks for in detail oh my gosh my
ears started hurting for some reason got
warm in there oh this is a mess that's
what it is
we had it Mama's room into my ear
[Music]
[Applause]